I got a lot of placenta in my mouth just
now not the first time not the first
time hey what's going on everybody from
first we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at
you from sunrise Mart in Soho where I'm
joined by a familiar face Joe G is back
in the building
how's it going fellas the new EP in
tongues is out now and then the single
18 with trippy red Chris woo and rich
Brian it's all over the place but before
Joe G was climbing up the charts he was
coming of age nearly 7,000 miles away in
Japan and that's why we're here at
sunrise mark one of the only Japanese
markets in New York City to get the
convenience our cheat codes even Joe G
himself we pulling out some of the most
beloved Japanese snacks to figure out if
they're really worth the 34-hour
round-trip flight but before we get
started you know the convenience store
it's such a big part of culture in Japan
it is the culture sometimes you'll go to
a 7-eleven in Japan you'll get better
food than you will in this New York City
restaurants what are some of the major
differences between you know the corner
store in New York City and then the
convenience stores that you'll find in
Japan one of the biggest differences is
in Japan or in other parts of Asia too
the people are like really overworked so
7-eleven Family Mart Lawson's I think
one of their biggest things that they're
doing is to cater to most of Japan which
are people who don't want to cook for
themselves but still want really good
food you know that's great because you
know I wasn't sure if maybe my notes
were right but I had it in there Joe G
used to work at a family can actually
beat to that what do you remember about
working at Family Mart actually it was a
Lawson's it was a lot it's it's the same
thing I say family R because that's what
everyone knows more but it was a
Lawson's you know I did the night shift
it was it was chill the only people that
came in at night were like truckers and
stuff so that's actually where I
wrote a lot of lot of music when I was
in there just like on the back of
receipts
that's just the night shift that is the
night shift that Lawson is is fire all
right Joe gee i could talk shop with you
all day but I'm hungry it's time to
browse the aisles just show me what to
get and afterwards we'll have a little
snack sessions that's how good let's go
[Music]
all right so here we are in the instant
noodles section and when you think about
instant noodles you know you always
think cup noodles or top ramen but here
it's a total buffet when you look at all
the labels all the pictures here what
are you there on - we gotta go with this
this is number one number when I eat
this [ __ ] all the time it's some curry
[ __ ] no added msg that's weird
that's very rare I've never seen that
before it might not be as good then so
in Japan you'll find a fire ramen shop
on every corner futon on every corner
why are instant noodles such a big deal
when you know on the market you have so
many other options
I think people secretly enjoy the
quality and like it takes no time to
make this [ __ ] right
so I think they're they're drawn to that
luckily most of the convenience stores
in Japan have a thing ready with the hot
water in it because there's so many
people that come through that just want
the instant noodles so you can make it
right there on the spot and you take it
out in front like squatting like good
this is like this is true Asia everyone
knows what's up with this and the
cigarette you gotta have the cigarette
in one hand alright so here we are in
the snack aisle and off rip catching my
eye sriracha
no big deal popcorn so this is already
an aisle after my heart because I'm
gonna be drawn to here first of all
let's get the Pocky stuff out of here
that's not that's a no-go that's not
basic stuff well let's talk about Pocky
for just a second because that's had a
huge crossover explosion you guys any
gas station any convenience store in the
United States you'll find Pocky sticks
but they're not for you huh no pockys
great I'm just being an [ __ ] about it
I'm just being a snob
[ __ ] that what are you into here this
has always been like a go to like I feel
like every every kid in Japan knows this
and they love it it's called a quad
honor machi meaning the march of the
koalas this is a strawberry flavor it's
actually my personal favorite this [ __ ]
is called talking Oakland or some [ __ ]
they're like baby bamboo shoots but just
like chocolate but this is actually an
offshoot of Kinoko no Yama mean yeah
which is like mountain of mushrooms and
it's exactly this except they're
mushrooms it's really [ __ ] stupid but
kids love it but the thing is though
like low-key
I like American candy better I was
longing for that [ __ ] like I tried Jolly
Ranchers once when I was in like middle
school and I was like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] dude the Jolly Ranchers are
nuts
alright well we can't end our shopping
adventure without hitting the skin care
i'll i know that skin care it's such a
huge deal to people in japan it is why
well it's it's a huge deal with in Asia
in general because they have an
obsession with keeping their their
youthfulness and also they're just
terrified of wrinkles so they they have
all this anti-wrinkle [ __ ] like the
female products get like crazy like this
says placenta this is it's it's it's a
sentient face man I've seen a lot of
commercials about this they would they
take they take women's placentas I guess
like I don't know house they'd get their
hands on
Essenza but they take women's placentas
and apparently placenta juice is really
good for your face well you can see that
it's so important they would resort to
placenta juice if it keeps you youthful
you got to do what you got to do guys do
what you got to do it's it's it's a I'll
put anything on my face all right that's
a good spot to say you know we've hit
the aisles I think there's nothing left
to do but grab a table and try some of
the things that we've pulled off the
shelf today absolutely let's do it yep
all right at long last it's finally time
to eat here we are at the taste test
we're gonna have our favorite instant
noodles we're gonna have our favorite
candies but first things first we're
starting in the chip category hangzhou
gene yes what the hell is this
this is I never I never [ __ ] with this
too much but it's definitely like like
we said earlier it's definitely in the
chip genus it's known to be kind of
spicy you're the spice man so why don't
you let let us know what level this is
for you that's not spicy is that's no
big deal that's no big I said no big
deal I see if you had juggling chili
peppers yeah I don't know what they're
eating what is like kind of a bad cheeto
yeah that's what it is it's a bad sheet
oh it's a bad cheeto what are you are
you into these Joji
me I don't have to give this a solid a 2
out of 10 right I'm a little nicer Joji
I'll give it a 4 out of 10 all right but
I'm not a repeat customer I see this on
the shelf
I'm keeping it on the shelf but
curiously you pulled these I did pull
those yeah this is a Joe G wild card
it's dried fish with almonds is right
fish with almonds and it really looks
like dried fish with almonds it really
lives that life
mmm fishing nutty but a little sweet
hypersthene no troll like I really do
like these when I think about what Joji
might snack on I think I would draw this
just fishing nuts
that's all I eat I mean it it kind of is
all a solid eight out of ten right there
eight out of ten that's a good one yeah
I'd give it a 10 - all right up next
it's another Joji special what we have
here is our cup noodle curry and now
usually you know maybe you're at your
dorm you get some instant noodles this
is next-level that great curry smell
what's the most impressive about this
thing is like look at the size of the
potato in there right right
and look how soft you know it just
breaks it's like it's actual like a
restaurant yeah they're not starch
they're not [ __ ] around
so here we go I can tell it's hot don't
burn yourself jouji turn on some chords
oh yeah that's good
that must be in the nine category that
was the yeah it was like at 8.45 what do
you think
so here's they'll have to say about this
yeah it's so good right it's so much
better and then whatever Top Ramen you'd
get or whatever cup of noodle that you'd
get and then you get a big hearty fill
your belly meal for get this a dollar
seventy nine so when you start playing
in that game I don't know how you can
call this anything but an A+ that's all
you can call this anything but a 10 out
of 10 because how do you spend a dollar
79 on a meal better than this
here we are with our dessert course
there are sweets
jouji set the table for us what are we
eating here today we have little
chocolate pies they crumble in your
mouth and they're adorable they look
like little pies cooling on the
windowsill flaky pie crust that you get
they do a good job I'm surprised they
really do mimic the pie in almost every
way but sighs yeah which is actually
much more convenient Oh like sometimes
you're like I can eat a whole pie
I can eat a whole pie now I can eat two
pies three pies four pies go ahead count
it up mmm - I do like them I'm given
that an 8 out of 10 you know that is uh
that's a that's an interesting sort of
first experience but that kind of snack
and I don't definitely feedback what
about you Joe Jean
yeah I'd probably give it a 8 out this
is ninja shoe it's made out of plum plum
is very much like it or hate it sort of
vibe in Japan like if there's like a
product you bet your ass is a plum
flavor there's such a super [ __ ] up
it's for the old people it's for the old
people I'm gonna I'm gonna try something
with you it's bad huh so I'm eating it
right now it's bitter
it has a tea quality and then it's
difficult to chew I chopped it up I'm
not gonna lie to you I've never had
these I've had different flavors of this
mm-hmm
but this is like I think this is meant
to like [ __ ] with you I'm just trying to
chew I'm thinking if I move my head
faster I'll chew faster gotta wash that
down ah oh okay
overall I would say it's an unpleasant
experience top of Joji I can see that
you're going through that's bad I'd
rather be too hot watch this is really
bad
alright well there you have it it's the
highs and lows of the Japanese
convenience store experience I could not
have brought along a better companion
sir
jouji my friend she'll bless the ropes
in tongues the EP pick it up now it's
nothing but smackers
thank you till next time Internet I'm
Sean Evans and for all of your Japanese
snack needs you got to come here sunrise
Mart it's the place to be
[Music]
Wow does it smell like placenta or will
not know it's serious you know like it
smells serious yeah it smells like birth
some sort of birth related thing
time for some placenta masks placenta
you gotta lean back a little and let it
let it settle in then it doesn't feel
bad no it actually feels kind of nice
we've gotta learn ice and beer and
facial cheers Cheers
to Japan and placenta masks